this feels a little bit like getting
that bicycle you really wanted for your
11 year old Christmas except you're
getting it when you're 18
so Marvel has finally made the first
concrete move towards a black widow
silver movie by hiring a screenwriter
for it before I get into my thoughts on
this quick little bit of housekeeping so
I have now got the patreon up and
running and I have sat down and actually
figured out a schedule for how things
are going to look for this channel for
actually the next few months now a more
detailed version of what I'm planning
that is on the patreon n is patron
exclusive but here's a few broad strokes
that I kind of want everyone to know for
some things that I am now setting in
stone so you can kind of set your
expectations for scheduling dr. who
gonna be weekly gonna be on Sundays
every Sunday Doctor Who video black
mirror reviews that's gonna be Wednesday
every Wednesday new black mirror review
you know until I finish out the whole
thing other than that stuff bumps around
you know shifts and things may continue
to change us knees go on but those are
the two things I'm locking right now
wanted everyone to know that but that's
enough marble making a black widow movie
hooray
took you dang time didn't it the thing
is I say hooray I'm actually I'm kind of
annoyed and irritated with Marvel at
this point especially the timing of this
announcement doesn't do them any favors
because they as I said they've hired a
screenwriter named Jack Schaeffer I
despite the name Jack I it is in fact a
woman I don't think she's had anything I
actually filmed at this point but she
has a script on the black list so she's
been writing for a while and getting a
script on the black list which if you
don't know is a collection of the best
unproduced screenplays one of her works
was already snatched up by Natalie
Portman and is being worked on and
getting something on the black list is a
pretty solid benchmark for someone who
hasn't had a film produced yet so
honestly that's a decent sign I like
that they hired a woman to write it and
again I'm not - anyone can write
anything but I think it's probably a
smart
thing to get a female perspective at in
this thing as early as possible so that
you know that it's there and you're not
having to look at something that a team
of guys have been working on for months
or a year and going are we sure we've
got the right perspective on this like
get it in there at the beginning and
then adjust as you go however you need
to but like I said the timing on this is
I want to say it's suspect but it's
unfortunate because it was only a couple
days ago that there was a trailer for a
movie called red Sparrow now I don't
know how widespread the viewing of this
trailer was it's a movie starring
Jennifer Lawrence which I know a lot of
people's pictures especially in geek
circles don't really like her they kind
of hold her portrayal of mystique
against her as an actress it seems like
but look if you haven't seen this
trailer already go look up just just
search red Sparrow trailer I'll probably
actually put a link in the description
check it out come on back and you'll
probably see what I mean I'll wait see
MIT ok cool look like a Black Widow
origin movie didn't it like incredibly
so so you really do feel like Marvel you
waited too long you should have moved on
this a long time ago aside from the fact
that there was no reason not to move on
this a lot sooner they they're right
there truly was no good reason not to be
working on a black widow movie way
before this but now you look reactive
now it looks like the only reason you're
moving forward is because somebody else
came up and basically ate your lunch or
you know they will if the movie is any
good I bet you right now Disney is
really crossing his fingers hoping to
God red Sparrow is not good but even if
it isn't and it doesn't stick in the
public consciousness it's still gonna
paint the idea of getting a Black Widow
origin movie cuz it's gonna be covering
that same ground so unless it completely
dies of the box office rents pair made
completely kneecapped and he hopes that
a Black Widow origin now that's not to
say we couldn't get some hints of an
origin you could tell a story of her
more modern day you could do you know
before we've seen her but not
necessarily origin origin if you were to
do say how she first came into shield
things like that could work we could get
little flashes of way back but they
now gonna have to keep an eye on this
movie and basically build around not
copying it and that that's that is
unfortunate and I would be more
sympathetic like I said if they hadn't
waited it so dang long Disney Marvel you
guys waited so long this is your fault
there is no one to blame but yourself
the public was ready we wanted the fans
we wanted a black widow movie you didn't
give it to us now there's a movie that
looks really dead-set like a black widow
origin movie and it came in to fill the
void cuz you weren't doing anything I
don't have a ton of thoughts about what
I think they should or shouldn't do I
just really irritated at the situation
more so because it shouldn't happen
there is absolutely no reason this ever
should have been the case and we found
ourselves with Black Widow having to do
something other than a no like and again
I'm not saying they had to ever do an
order to movie but now that's basically
just been cleared off the plate because
somebody else came in and did it I in
some ways it almost felt like atomic
blonde could have been a a black widow
movie but this this one more than
anything the red Sparrow oh god yeah it
does all that bitching aside I am
looking forward to this because I I
think that the Marvel Cinematic Universe
could use a pure espionage movie and
they could have done it with Black Widow
they could have done it with Nick Fury
and AH say it would have been fine with
either as far as filling that particular
niche I think they should be making a
black widow movie even if they did do a
Nick Fury solo movie but you know you've
got you've got shield and I know we have
agents of shield as a TV show but that
that is very much steeped in the the
supernatural superheroes super
technology aspects I I want to see
Marvel's version of a down-and-dirty
espionage movie give me a MacGuffin give
me you know has to sneak into an enemy
facility during a big Gala Ball to
recover a day to dislike give me that
give me the Marvel version of that
that's what I want that's what Black
Widow is friggin perfect for so if I get
over my just frustration that
took this long to do it I am excited
about this like I said at this point I
don't I don't know if I want red sparrow
to be any good or not I'm sure Disney
doesn't want it to be any good but I
look at that trail and go this looks
like a movie I want to see I wish I was
seeing it with black widow but I like if
it's successful is that gonna kneecap
you know what black widow could be if it
fails is that better for black widow is
it worse because then will they see it
as a as proof that audiences don't want
that I don't know I don't like my
expectations of black widow movie now
being tied to something else and
unfortunately right now they just kind
of are so those are my thoughts on the
announcement that Black Widow at the
very least has a screenwriter attached
this is way early days yet there's no
director there whatever script gets
written it still has to be green lifts
there's a long way to go but it's the
first concrete stuff beyond just people
that Marvel going yeah that would be
nice wouldn't it it's about time those
are my thoughts what are yours whatever
they are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it do all the
stuff like subscribe Twitter or email my
patreon you know if you're feeling
generous links for all that stuff it's
all down below and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]